let's say we're told that zero is equal
to x squared plus 6x plus three what is
an X or what our X is that would satisfy
this equation pause this video and try
to figure it out
alright now let's work through it
together so the first thing that I would
try to do is see if I could factor this
right hand expression I have some
expression it's equal to zero so if I
could factor it that might help solve so
let's see can I think of two numbers
that when I add them I get six and when
I take their product I get positive
three well if I'm thinking just in terms
of integers three is a prime number it
only has two factors one and three and
let's see one plus three is not equal to
six so it doesn't look like factoring is
going to help me much so the next thing
I'll turn to is completing the square in
fact completing the square to if there
if there are way if there are x-values
that would satisfy this equation
completing the square will help us solve
it and the way I do it I'll say zero is
equal to let me rewrite the first part x
squared plus 6x and then I'm going to
write the plus three out here and my
goal is is to add something to this
equation or to the right-hand expression
right over here and then I'm going to
subtract that same thing so I'm not
really changing the value of the
right-hand side and I want to add
something here that I'm later going to
subtract so that what I have in
parenthesis is a perfect square well the
way to make it a perfect square and we
talked about this in other videos when
we introduced ourselves to completing
the square is we'll look at this first
degree coefficient right over here this
positive six and say okay half of that
is positive three and if we were to
square that we would get nine so let's
add a nine there and then we could also
subtract a nine notice we haven't
changed the value of the right-hand side
expression we're adding nine and we're
subtracting nine and actually the
parentheses are just there to help it
make a little bit more visually clear to
us but you don't even need the
parenthesis you would essentially get
the same result
but then what happens if we simplify
this a little bit well what I just
showed you let me do it in this green
blue color this thing can be re-written
as X plus three squared that's why we
added nine there
we said all right we're gonna be dealing
with a 3 because 3 is half of 6 and if
we squared 3 we get a 9 there and then
this second part right over here 3 minus
9 that's equal to negative 6 so we could
write it like this 0 is equal to X plus
3 squared minus 6 and now what we can do
is isolate this X plus 3 squared by
adding 6 to both sides so let's do that
let's add 6 there let's add 6 there and
what we get on the left hand side we get
6 is equal to on the right hand side we
just get X plus 3 X plus 3 squared and
now we can take the square root of both
sides and we could say that the plus or
minus square root of 6 is equal to is
equal to X plus 3 and if this doesn't
make full sense just pause the video a
little bit and think about it if I'm
saying that something squared is equal
to 6 that means that the something is
either going to be the positive square
root of 6 or the negative square root of
6 and so now we can if we want to solve
for X we can just subtract 3 from both
sides so let's subtract 3 from both
sides and what do we get we get on the
right-hand side we just are left with an
X and that's going to be equal to
negative 3 plus or minus the square root
of 6 and we are done and obviously we
could rewrite this as say X could be
equal to negative 3 plus the square root
of 6 or X could be equal to negative 3
minus the square root of 6